[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bon soit
aulas vieux poêle patron je me sens en
pleine forme d'un billet nounours moi
aussi ma petite folle l'hérault hop hop
hop hop hop hop aurum
alors il n'y a personne
elle ne fait pas de prix ça sent la
pharmacie
[Musique]
mon dieu ce n'est pas mon petit nicolau
g qu'alors je vais te tuer 3 7 passes
des tisanes et attention c'est très
chiant moi je trouve les médicaments
périmés
ou le bas ce fonds
mechaal et repos
maladie médicaments tels médicaments
jeunesse et mon agent me plaît et de la
bonne tisane au petit nico lorsqu'elle
avait atteint 10,1 et des bonnes équipes
mais tu as tort nicolas c'est délicieux
les médicaments j'aime beaucoup les
médicaments et je vais en prendre pour
ne pas attraper la grippe nous la
politisant
là où
le merveilleux sur au cap
oui deux pilules c'est ce qu'il ya de
meilleur tu parles tu fais peut-être une
petite friction pas eu une petite mais
une grande assiette ouais tu vois
nicollin eh bien elle ne pas vouloir
toutes ces bonnes choses bon ça oui
alors tu ne regrette rien moi c'est mon
fardeau à friction patronales
[Musique]
[Rires]
ou
pas si fort où le mot quelle force
ou le nom au rouge très bonne
coordination
lui une relation
[Musique]
ce que j'ai chaud je transpire merci pas
pr neil je me sens bien au sco jeune
franck
nicolas renter médicaments demain si tu
veux être guéri
d'accord nano cela
j'éteins la lumière
ce que je me sens bien
[Musique]
ah voici notre nounou freaks
je me sens tout drôle patron tu as pris
trop de médicaments on ne prend pas de
médicaments quand on n'est pas malade je
me sens tout genre allons en route gros
nigaud h bonne nuit les enfants photo
bourg
[Musique]
m